هو أن كل الدخان المنبعث من الإطارات
تم نشر قوات الأمن
عبر طرق العاصمة ، وتم
إغلاق الإنترنت وتم تقييد الوصول إلى وسائل الإعلام
بشدة ، نريد بلدًا
يمكننا العيش فيه ، لقد مرت 16 عامًا هذا
الشاب يصرخ أنني خريج جامعة
ليس لديه عمل ، العديد من
المتظاهرين هم شباب البلاد
الذين ترتفع نسبة البطالة بينهم بشكل
خاص ، يقول رجل آخر هنا إنه
درس القانون ، والعمل الوحيد الذي وجده هو في
صالون لتصفيف الشعر يقول إنه كان
يتظاهر لأيام وهم يصرخون على
بعضهم البعض  حول استخدام الحكومة
للقوة ، فإن أصدقاءهم الذين قُتلوا
في المظاهرات ، والظلم الذي ظل هذا
الرجل الذي لا يريد
الكشف عن هويته ، كان يصور منذ
البداية كل ذلك ،
لا يوجد شيء تعتقد أن
الناس لم يهاجموا
قوات الأمن  كان سلاحنا الوحيد هو
قطع الطريق ماديًا حتى
لا تتمكن قوات الأمن من دفع
المتظاهرين ، مطالبهم ليست
غير منطقية على حد قوله.  والفساد
يوفران فرص العمل ويحسنان الخدمات الأساسية ،
لكن الاحتجاجات أصبحت أكثر عنفًا
مما يهدد الأمن الهش بالفعل في هذا البلد
،
وقد أثار ارتفاع عدد القتلى غضب أولئك الذين يحاولون النزول
إلى الشوارع. هذا الفيديو من اليوم
الثالث عندما كان لا يزال هناك حظر
تجول.  من الصعب حقًا النظر إليه
نظرًا لوجود رجل على الأرض
مصاب بجرح في الرأس ، يكون صوت
إطلاق النار ثابتًا بعد بضع دقائق ، حيث
شوهد رجل آخر ينزف من
جرح طلق ناري يقول إن كل ما يريدونه هو
أن يتم سماعهم.  القتل يناشد
الاستماع إلى ما يريدون إرسال شخص
من الحكومة ليقول إنني هنا
لأتحدث إليكم ما الذي تحتاجه
النقطة المحورية في بغداد للمظاهرات
محاطة بحلقة أمنية في
الكابيتول متوترة على حافة الهاوية
الحكومة تدعو إلى الهدوء  وتعهدت
بالتصدي لمطالب المتظاهرين
بوعود سمعها السكان من قبل
لكن الكلمات الجوفاء لن تخنق
غضب الناس بعد الآن.